[Musica]
Alessio è un bambino di 7 anni è uno di
quei bambini un po' scomodi uno di
quelli a cui piace fare casino
Ha un difetto ama giocare e divertirsi e
ci prova proprio in quel posto in cui
gli dicono di non farlo la scuola
io lo conosco e se gli dessero la
possibilità direbbe maestra ma io qui ci
sto tutto il giorno e quando devo
giocare
nota
per adesso stare seduto 8 ore su una
piccola sedia di legno è piuttosto
scomodo e terribilmente noioso
però nessuno gli ha mai dato la
possibilità di esprimere la sua opinione
altrimenti probabilmente direbbe maestro
Mi fa male il sedere e mi annoio mi vien
da dormire se sto con la stessa vista
della stessa posizione per tutto questo
tempo
nota
E io invece no vorrei che Alessio
continuasse ad agitarsi in quella
piccola sedia Perché ho paura Ho paura
che se invece si dovesse abituare a
stare seduto composto per 8 ore questo
possa addirittura piacergli di più che
muoversi E così chi sa passare dal banco
al divano per il resto del suo poco e
prezioso tempo
per Alessio a volte seguire la maestra
che spiega la lavagna è un po' faticoso
e si confonde con le scritte fitte fitte
del sussidiario
nessuno però gli ha insegnato a proporre
un'idea perché altrimenti probabilmente
direbbe maestra scelto il
torrente dietro la scuola possiamo
andare lì a studiare il ciclo dell'acqua
o Alessio non scherziamo hai idea delle
responsabilità
rassicurazione le burocrazie ma non se
ne parla neanche ma ti ho capito non hai
voglia di fare niente
Torna al tuo posto e mettiti a studiare
e comunque nota
la conoscenza acquisita per obbligo non
fa presa nella mente Quindi non usate
l'obbligo ma lasciate che la prima
educazione sia una sorta di divertimento
questo vi metterà maggiormente in grado
di capire l'inclinazione naturale del
bambino Queste sono le parole di un
grande maestro Platone
e i greci la sapevano lunga Quindi
rimaniamo sulle parole la parola scuola
da cosa deriva
dal greco scuole che
pensate significa svago tempo libero
qualcosa è andato storto o quantomeno
Alessio ha ragione
voi Che parola avete pensato
con la scuola provando a richiamare le
emozioni lasciamo da parte le risposte
giuste e il buon senso le emozioni del
passato
aiutiamoci con un ricordo il colloquio i
genitori insegnanti esentati tutti
quelli che prendevano 10 Io me lo
ricordo benissimo e aspettavo i miei
genitori a casa con un nodo allo stomaco
un ansia pazzesca
per poi in realtà sentirmi dire sempre
la solita frase per 13 anni di
scolarizzazione del mantra era sempre
quello è intelligente ma non si applica
Ecco appunto è familiare No E perché
eravamo in tanti a far parte di questa
categoria evidentemente sbagliavamo
tutti e invece forse non è così Io oggi
sto scherzarci Però ricordo molto bene
come quel giudizio mi facesse sentire mi
diceva tu non sei abbastanza E io per
Anni Ci ho creduto
oggi ai genitori chiedo se vorrebbero lo
stesso per i vostri figli
Purtroppo penso che bambini a scuola
non comunichino con lo stesso linguaggio
la scuola dice Tu non ti applichi Sì ma
secondo quali parametri le griglie di
valutazione i programmi
peraltro aboliti
ribaltiamo lo sguardo un bambino va
dalla scuola e gli dice scuola e io ci
provo ad esprimermi però tu non mi
capisci forse sei tu che non ti applichi
abbastanza
per un per tanto tempo ho provato a
immaginare quale potesse essere una
scuola ideale poi sono approdata nel
mondo dell'educazione parentale Che
cos'è l'educazione parentale è una
scelta tutelata dalla costituzione che
un genitore fa quando vuole prendersi
carico dell'Istruzione del proprio
figlio e lo può fare sia assumendo lui
il ruolo di maestro e quindi quello che
conosciamo come Old schooting sia
aderendo creando un progetto educativo
ed è lì che io mi colloco mi piace
spiegare i progetti educativi come una
ricetta una ricetta ben riuscita
ingredienti di qualità Ben calibrati
lo spazio
lo spazio deve essere accogliente bello
Abbiamo stanze piene di Puff cuscini
coperte
un bambino deve sentirsi a casa
abbiamo anche i banchi ovviamente solo
che non sono dei perimetri militari
oltre il quale si è fuori posto ma hanno
la loro funzione di piani d'appoggio
Inoltre uno spazio deve essere
modulabile perché un bambino per avere
uno sviluppo cognitivo efficace
deve potersi muovere
siamo mente ma siamo anche corpo
il numero in una classe non ci sono più
di 10 massimo 12 bambini questo perché
l'adulto deve poter dedicare uno sguardo
a ciascuno lo sguardo che merita
per poter capire di un bambino i
desideri i talenti le difficoltà le
paure e quindi fare su di lui un metodo
educativo specifico
Io credo che questo punto in realtà
possa essere ben compreso dagli
insegnanti perché spesso si ritrovano
piuttosto che a insegnare o educare a
gestire classiche pensate arrivano a 30
bambini un'impresa
Inoltre si tratta di pluriclassi Cioè
abbiamo bambini di età diverse dentro e
questo punto preoccupa molto spesso
invece credo sia uno dei più arricchenti
di questi progetti perché io vedo
bambini piccoli
gasati stimolati ad arrivare al livello
dei più grandi con cui ovviamente si
possono relazionare e i più grandi che
invece fanno i maestri quelle che si
chiamava per Education educazione
cascata insegnando ai più piccoli
adottano strategie cognitive diverse Gli
permettono di apprendere due volte
fissare tutto nella loro testa
poi lo sbaglio una cosa che per me è
fondamentale è togliere l'ansia
dell'errore
bisogna sbagliare ai miei bambini lo
dico sempre se stai sbagliando Stai
prendendo qualcosa di nuovo e quindi va
bene
immaginatevi la serenità di poter
inciampare
E per ultimo il grande protagonista di
questi progetti è il gioco
Rodari diceva vale la pena che un
bambino impari piangendo ciò che può
imparare ridendo
Ecco io questo messaggio l'ho fatto mio
eppure vi garantisco assistito a questa
scena di una maestra di arte che ha gran
voce diceva i suoi alunni non siamo qui
per divertirci
pugno nello stomaco e invece no noi
siamo lì per divertirci per accendere il
desiderio appassionarci
perché se non c'è la parte del
divertimento Un bambino prende per forza
e non gli apprendimenti vengono
trattenuti dal cervello solo il tempo di
essere vomitati all'interrogazione
e invece noi l'obiettivo sarebbe la
durata l'autenticità
Il fatto è che i vostri figli sono tutti
meravigliosamente diversi e io mi sento
chiamata a enfatizzare questa diversità
non posso
standardizzarli e normalizzarli perché
quel per quel famoso futuro migliore Un
mondo di innovazione non abbiamo bisogno
di adulti adeguati abbiamo bisogno di
adulti creativi originali
A tal proposito c'è un bellissimo
aneddoto che Ken Robinson riportò nel
suo tet Talk Tous Kill crediti ovvero La
scuola uccide la creatività
c'era questa bambina di 8 anni che non
apprendeva si agitava si distraeva a
scuola i genitori vengono convocati e
poi la portano da uno specialista
questo specialista parla con la bambina
con la mamma lo osserva poi Invita la
madre a uscire insieme vanno nella sala
di controllo a osservare la bimba da
sola rimasta nella stanza
questo signore accende la radio che
risuona nella stanza della bambina e
questa cosa fa si mette a ballare a
muoversi a ritmo di musica
lo specialista Allora guarda la madre e
gli dice signora
sua figlia non è malata è una ballerina
lei scrive una scuola di danza
ecco quella bambina è Gillian Lean la
coreografa del musical di fama mondiale
Chez
Ecco dobbiamo Tanto a lei a livello
artistico quanto a quest'uomo che ha
saputo guardare
Il fatto è che proprio quando sono
bambini che non vanno inchiodati a una
sedia Bisogna fargli fare cose fargli
fare esperienze
la scienza ha dimostrato che un bambino
quando nasce a un numero di connessioni
sinaptiche molto superiori a quelli di
un adulto
immaginiamo i loro cervelli come con
tante lampadine accese
poi cosa succede
nella fascia di età dai 5 ai 13 anni
queste lampadine
si spengono se non utilizzate Queste
connessioni sinaptiche vengono recise
questo fenomeno Si chiama pruning
Quindi quelle lampadine spente però che
cos'erano erano quelle risorse
potenziali che avrebbero reso più facile
più veloce un futuro eventuale nuovo
apprendimento quindi cose Come suonare
uno strumento musicale piuttosto che
imparare una seconda lingua se non si è
stati esposti da bambini all'ascolto
della musica o di una lingua saranno
processi che partiranno da zero faticosi
E allora mi chiedo vale la pena lasciare
che queste lampadine si spengano
perché dipende da noi dipende dal
contesto in cui scegliamo di immergere i
bambini dal tipo di apprendimento che
vogliamo dedicare loro
vedete
è evidente che ci sia tanto potenziale e
creativo pronto per essere coltivato
un bambino la mattina si alza e sceglie
chi io che cosa essere con totale
freschezza e spensieratezza un leone e
un guerriero un astronauta voi che cosa
eravate da bambini Io per esempio avevo
due lavori part time ero una veterinaria
di giorno e un ninja di notte
e l'appello che io faccio è quello di
continuare a nutrire i loro sogni perché
non c'è un tempo per smettere
ed è soltanto così che si può coltivare
questo potenziale creativo che gli
permetterà di scegliere ancora in
maniera però consapevole Chi vuole
essere da adulti
James Matthew Barry nel suo famoso
romanzo Peter Pan
scrisse se dubiti di poter volare perdi
per sempre la facoltà di farlo
adesso la scuola per come è rimasta
tutt'oggi non rende possibile quello che
io ho la fortuna di vivere tutti i
giorni
di vedere realizzare davanti ai miei
occhi
Ma nella speranza di attesa che qualcosa
cambi sappiamo che delle alternative
esistono
non vi voglio lasciare con le mie parole
ma con quelle di una mia bambina Camilla
il cui foglietto è qui
Camilla cos'è per te la scuola
per me la scuola a volte è un po' noiosa
come quando sto a tre ore a guardare in
aria
Alcune volte è tanto stancante per colpa
della confusione
Alcune volte è bello e mi diverto come
quando faccio l'intervallo
e Camilla Com'è la scuola che vorresti
Vorrei una scuola dove si impara
disegnando dove gli intervalli ci sono
le altalene gli alberi per arrampicarsi
e le maestre sono gentili
Vorrei una classe piena di disegni e
lavoretti tutta colorata
mi piacerebbe studiare una materia
inventata da me e la chiamerei primavera
perché vorrei studiare i fiori le
montagne e la natura però la vorrei
studiare fuori da scuola
[Applauso]